Tế mà chúng ta y và kỳ nhóm mà được sự rộng hộ sĩ bởi vì nó không mà.
Thì doa tảy rằng là kỳ nhóm mà được sự rộng hộ sĩ bởi vì nó hạn chế tới trên năm 2019.
Trên bởi với hình chẳng các vui cơ thệ nạc, đặc biệt là các đẩn đề liệt và nè từ phòng.
Tổ ra là chúng ta y rằng với kỳ nước độ ra như thế thì cái ra chỉ cũng bụi tiêm rất lớn.
Tao sụ phụ của Vasi cú đã rất là nhỏ là khoảng qua.
Bởi vì ín cay nhằn mà bản thân chúng tôi như vì trong anh y tế tôi cũng đã tiêm dự phòng để kìa làm.
Tao sụ phụ của anh như là không có chịu xuất nè nhưng mà khoảng rất là nhàng.
Mình cách đau không làm anh dưới miếng bệnh.
Mó nó chỉ tốt hơn, bệnh đến.
Thống gì thế giới là giọt giọt giọt giọt giọt giọt.
và hãy tên vòng và xí cụng hàng năm, ngoặc 1 gần thì nhá hạn bình lên để dự phòng cụng.
Và ký vị xíu phòng cụng này nó có được hậu phẫn, bởi vì ai nghĩa một chuyên này nhé tính,
ở nghĩa là hội nhạm dự phòng bỏ bỏ lỗi cà.
Những người có mạnh này như là thậu tại ra được thì có khi phậu tại ra được phó kỳ, khi phậu tại ra được,
cho vào đều khuyên dự phòng cụng hàng năm, hội,
mạnh, các phù hội phù hội tình,
hội của cộng khuy cà, mạnh hội hội hội phía trạc,
của cộng khuyên cà, và vấn đất,
tất cả những cái đế lấy được khuyên cà,
tất là chúng ta làm việc là 100% về mặt của bên tắc,
về mặt học thật, cũng như tính là tỏa thì ở đều hội tụ cả,
và nếu xác rửa thương thì chúng tôi cũng trái rửa tương đến,
soạn vời thân trong gia đình, bao gồm cọc 1 mẹ chúng ta đều ở trong mặt càng liên dầu,
là cục khuyên và cục đi tìm phòng.